since that we're with you you know we're
standing shoulder to shoulder with you
where you know we're far away but we're
with you we'll be with you so yeah I
think that they should know that that we
stand with them in their struggle well
we're here for you basically and we will
be every step of the way lundi tonight
after the deaths of Alton sterling at
the Lando Castille we're asking people
what's one thing they want Americans
watching this to know about how the rest
the world sees what's going on in the US
meat meat meat power power power to the
black Americans power
we are covered to show solidarity for
the US and the killings that happened
there it's not okay in it
and we need to show it black men are
constantly getting killed in America and
it's like they're trying to make us
extinct or so and you know I mean and
what brought it home is just thinking
about that could have been my brother
because I've got a younger brother so I
think that's what made it more that's
what brought it home for me every single
country boycotts in South Africa
sporting events in order to stop my
partner I think the similar unity is
needed in order to stop the racial
tensions in America it's easy to brush
it off as an American problem but it
could easily happen over here injustice
has happened every single day and we
have to show that it's not okay well
America's are really close to us you
know they like our cousin's kind of
thing you know so we really connected in
that way and I'm a lot of the things
happened over there eventually up and
over here we can't let anything goes
over there sort not you know go I know
just enough the importance of white
people on these marches in that those
who aren't oppressed if they feel the
same and if they feel as at Regis we do
that is when we start
changing is completely outraged by the
way black people are being treated in
America and I come here to protest
against no
there's this until there's actual real
equality we've gotta keep doing this
kind of thing until something changes
yeah but I did not enough